***
Kommen Fische vom Great Barrier Reef
nach Sydney und wieder zurück?
Okay, Freunde!
Los, los!
Gibt es vegetarische Haie?
(Haie) Fische sind Freunde,
kein Futter.
Gibt es Fische mit Gedächtnisverlust?
Ich hatte was vor, aber was?
Wie realistisch ist die Welt
rund um Nemo und Dori?
Das finden wir heraus.
Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier!
Dieses Jahr werden es schon 20 Jahre,
dass "Findet Nemo" in die Kinos kam.
Ich erinnere mich gut,
wie ich ihn damals fand.
Auch wenn ich zugegebenermaßen
nicht mehr ganz ein Kind war.
Aber von der ganze Story und visuell
hat mich das gefesselt und abgeholt.
Ich habe mich aber nicht gefragt,
ob das wissenschaftlich funktioniert.
Selbst in so einem Kinderfilm
stecken jede Menge Science-Facts,
in die wir heute
richtig tief abtauchen werden.
Dafür habe ich mir Verstärkung geholt
von der Meeresbiologin
Julia Schnetzer.
Julia forscht in Bremerhaven
am Alfred-Wegener-Institut.
Sie untersucht, wie man Algen
als CO2-Speicher nutzen kann.
Das Great Barrier Reef kennt sie gut.
Dort hat sie
ihren Tauchschein gemacht.
Schön, dass du da bist.
- Hi!
Wenn du Filme wie "Findet Nemo"
oder "Findet Dori" guckst:
Kannst du das
unvoreingenommen machen?
Ich liebe die Filme.
Ich gucke sie mega gern.
Aber manchmal
kommt die Meeresbiologin durch.
Da fallen mir Sachen auf,
wo ich denke:
Die Fische könnten eigentlich
nicht so lange im Süßwasser sein.
Das würden die nicht überleben.
Sie brauchen Salzwasser?
Genau, das Süßwasser
würde in sie reinströmen.
Sie würden irgendwann platzen.
Das wäre nicht geeignet
für einen Kinderfilm.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie es bei den anderen Szenen ist.
Die kriegen wir jetzt
Stück für Stück präsentiert.
Das macht für uns
niemand Geringeres als Caro.
Es wird schnell klar,
dass mit Dori etwas nicht stimmt.
Sie ist sehr lustig.
Aber sie erinnert sich nicht,
was sie gerade gesagt hat.
Was war los?
Denk nach!
- Worüber?
Was du vor hast.
- Wann?
Den Gedächtnisschwund
hatte sie schon als kleiner Fisch.
Sie vermutet den Ursprung
in ihrer Familie.
Ich leide
unter Gedächtnisverschwund.
Ja!
- Genau das musst du sagen.
Danke, Caro.
Was wären die Filme ohne Dori?
Sie ist total süß.
Außerdem ist es ein Running Gag,
dass sie ständig alles vergisst.
Ich kann mich
gut damit identifizieren.
Ich vergesse ständig
mein Handy im Mietwagen.
Meinen Wohnungsschlüssel
lasse ich auch überall liegen.
Das ist teuer.
- Was sind deine Sachen?
Du brauchst ein System.
Der Schlüssel
ist immer in der Jackentasche,
das Handy in der Handtasche.
Ich habe kein Problem damit.
Daran muss ich noch arbeiten.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Was vergesst ihr ständig
oder was findet ihr gar nicht erst?
Schreibt es mir in die Kommentare.
Meins.
Ich habe mich gefragt:
Kann es Gedächtnisschwund
bei Fischen geben?
Es gibt ja die Meinung,
dass sich vor allem Goldfische
nur an die letzten 3 Sekunden
erinnern können.
Ich weiß nicht,
wo das Gerücht herkommt.
Ich gestehe:
Ich benutze es auch manchmal.
Aber es ist totaler Quatsch.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob du ein Aquarium hast?
Oder einige deiner Zuschauer?
Füttert man Fische
immer an der gleichen Stelle,
schwimmen sie immer wieder dorthin.
Die merken sich das.
Ich habe mal ein Experiment gesehen,
wo Fische richtig trainiert wurden.
Das war ein Goldfisch,
der "Autofahren" gelernt hat.
Das war ein Aquarium auf Rädern.
Eine Kamera
verfolgte seine Bewegungen.
Wenn er in eine Richtung schwamm,
bewegte er das Aquarium.
Ich kenne das Experiment auch,
das ist richtig witzig.
Da ging es darum, zu verstehen,
wie Fische räumlich sehen können.
Wie sie Räume wahrnehmen.
Deswegen wurde der Fisch trainiert,
sich mit dem Aquarium zu bewegen.
Um ihn so trainieren zu können,
braucht er ein Langzeitgedächtnis.
Sonst würde es nicht funktionieren.
Deshalb beweist das Experiment auch,
dass Fische ein Gedächtnis haben.
Nichts mit 3 Sekunden merken.
- Nee, das ist Quatsch.
Es gibt eine schöne Anekdote
von einem Psychologie-Professor.
Er hatte einen Teich mit Welsen.
Immer, wenn er sie fütterte,
rief er "Fish, Fish".
Nach 3 Tagen
haben die ersten Welse reagiert
und kamen auf diesen Ruf
angeschwommen.
Es waren insgesamt 19 Welse.
Das hat er eine Zeitlang gemacht.
Über den Winter
machte er aber eine Pause.
Als er im Frühjahr
wieder "Fish, Fish" rief,
kamen 14 von 19 Welsen
noch angeschwommen.
Das ist schon beeindruckend.
Aber dann machte er 5 Jahre Pause.
(lacht) Okay.
9 von den ursprünglich 19 Welsen
kamen nach 5 Jahren
immer noch angeschwommen.
Wow!
- Ganz schön krass.
Hättest du dir das merken können?
Ich weiß nicht,
was letzte Woche war.
Die haben sich also gemerkt,
dass dieser Ruf
mit Futter verbunden ist.
Ja, genau.
Man muss aber sagen:
Es ist eine Anekdote,
keine wissenschaftliche Studie.
Es ist nur ein Alltagsbeispiel.
Das Problem ist:
Es gibt nicht viel Forschung
zum Langzeitgedächtnis bei Fischen.
Es ist sehr aufwendig und teuer.
Du musst die Fische halten,
sie füttern für eine lange Zeit.
Du brauchst Forschungsgelder.
Da gibt es nicht so viel.
Deswegen
wissen wir darüber nur wenig.
Schade.
Kommen wir zurück zum Film.
Dort hat Dori den Gedächtnisschwund
schon als kleines Kind.
Los, zähl bis 10!
1, 2, 3 ...
Ähm, 4.
Ähm ...
Ich mag Sand.
Sand ist matschig.
Wäre es vorstellbar,
dass es angeboren ist?
Oder innerhalb der Familie
vererbt worden ist?
Dori gehört zur Familie
der Paletten-Doktorfische.
Einen kollektiven Gedächtnisverlust
haben die nicht, soweit ich weiß.
Bei Dori ist es extrem.
Sie würde im Leben
nicht weit kommen.
Was man sich vorstellen kann:
Dass sie eine Hirnverletzung
erlitten hat
und dadurch
Gedächtnisprobleme bekam.
Durch einen Schlag auf den Kopf.
Aber das betrifft nur das Individuum
und nicht die ganze Familie.
Das ist immerhin ein Ansatz.
Dann können wir hier festhalten:
Fische sind cleverer,
als wir uns das vorstellen mögen.
Einen angeborenen Gedächtnisschwund
gibt es nicht.
Irgendwas muss Dori passiert sein.
Was genau,
das bleibt das Geheimnis von Disney.
Nemo und sein Vater
leben in einer Anemone
im Great Barrier Reef in Australien.
Nemo wird von einem Taucher gefangen
und nach Sydney verschleppt.
Also machen sich Marlin und Dori
auf den Weg,
um Nemo zu retten.
Sie sollen
dem Ostaustralstrom folgen.
Der bringt sie
in den Hafen von Sydney.
*Sie schreien.*
So viel weiß ich:
Den Ostaustralstrom
gibt es wirklich.
Aber benutzen Fische
ihn als Unterwasser-Autobahn?
Den Ostaustralstrom
gibt es wirklich.
Er verläuft vom Great Barrier Reef
an der Ostküste Australiens
bis runter nach Sydney.
Er ist allerdings größer,
als er im Film dargestellt wird.
Er ist etwa 100 km breit
und ungefähr 1,5 km tief.
Wow!
Das ist ja ordentlich größer.
Ist er auch so schnell?
Dort sieht es aus
wie auf einer Wasserrutsche.
So extrem ist es nicht.
Er ist von der Fließgeschwindigkeit
doppelt so schnell wie die Elbe.
Er kommt auf etwa 7 km/h.
Das ist schon schnell.
Aber nicht so extrem,
wie es im Film dargestellt wird.
Klingt aber so,
als könnten ihn Fische benutzen,
um nach Sydney zu kommen.
Es ist so, dass um Sydney herum
immer wieder Fische gefunden werden,
die ins Great Barrier Reef gehören.
Auch Clownfische?
- Auch Clownfische.
Aber wahrscheinlich unfreiwillig.
Wir sehen auch im Film:
Clownfische brüten ihre Eier aus
und beschützen sie.
Wenn die Baby-Fische rauskommen,
brauchen sie ein neues Zuhause.
Die können nicht
alle am gleichen Ort leben.
Sie müssen also verteilt werden.
Dafür nutzen sie oft die Strömung,
weil sie noch nicht
so gut schwimmen können.
Wenn Baby-Clownfische
in den Ostaustralstrom geraten,
können sie durchaus
bis nach Sydney getragen werden.
Wir können festhalten:
Das haut hin und ist plausibel.
Das Coole an der Szene ist,
dass sie diese sehr
entspannten Schildkröten treffen.
Ist das realistisch?
Ja, durchaus.
Meeresschildkröten sind
gern im Ostaustralstrom unterwegs,
weil sie dort Nahrung finden
und chillen können.
Cool!
Allerdings muss man sagen:
Für Fische, die in Sydney landen,
hat es im echten Leben
leider nicht so ein Happy End
wie bei "Findet Nemo".
Warum?
Im Winter wird es in Sydney kalt.
Zu kalt für Tropenfische.
Die erfrieren dann leider.
- Nein.
Können die nicht zurückschwimmen
wie im Film?
Das Problem ist:
Der Ostaustralstrom
ist wie eine Einbahnstraße.
Die sind zu klein,
sie kommen nicht dagegen an.
Außen herum schwimmen wäre zu weit,
das schaffen sie nicht.
Oh Gott!
Das heißt, Dori, Nemo und Marlin
hängen in Sydney fest und erfrieren?
Keine kinderfreundliche Geschichte.
Dori und Nemo treffen 3 Haie.
Aber es sind keine normalen Haie.
Sie wollen keine Fische mehr essen.
Sie gründeten die Gruppe
"Fische sind Freunde, kein Futter".
(alle) "Ich bin ein lieber Hai
und keine hirnlose Fressmaschine.
Fische sind Freunde, kein Futter."
Haie sind in Filmen
meistens die Bösen.
Sie sollen uns Angst machen.
Das Bild von denen
sieht eher so aus:
"Eine hirnlose,
alles verschlingende Maschine."
Fahr zur Hölle, du Schwein.
*Knall*
Sicher ein Grund, weshalb Leute
häufig Angst vor Haien haben.
Ich finde Bruce
und seine Kollegen sympathisch,
vor allem,
weil ich selbst Vegetarier bin.
Wie ist es bei euch?
Fleisch ja oder nein?
Schreibt es mir in die Kommentare.
(Haie) "Wenn ich was ändern will,
muss ich mich zuerst selber ändern."
Vegetarische Haie,
das ist Quatsch, oder?
Wenn wir uns die Selbsthilfegruppe
genauer anschauen,
können wir 2 Kandidaten
ausschließen.
Das ist Bruce,
er ist ein Weißer Hai.
Und Hart, er ist ein Makohai.
Die beiden Haiarten sind Karnivore,
sie sind Fleisch- bzw. Fischfresser.
Verdauungssystem,
Stoffwechsel und Bakterien im Darm
sind darauf ausgelegt,
Fleisch und Fisch zu verwerten.
Sie können aus Pflanzen
nichts rausziehen?
Genau.
Das ist aber nicht
bei allen Haiarten so.
Wir haben noch eine Chance
beim Hammerhai.
Er hat einen nahen Verwandten:
den Schaufelnasen-Hammerhai.
Bester Name.
Ganze Werkzeugkiste dabei.
Die sind auch Fleischfresser.
Sie fressen zum Beispiel Krebse.
Aber auch Seegras.
Früher dachte man,
dass sie das aus Versehen machen.
Dass sie, wenn sie Krebse schnappen,
auch Seegras mit runterschlucken.
Aber eine neue Studie
hat 2018 gezeigt,
dass sie das tatsächlich
verdauen und verwerten können.
Es ist Nahrung.
Wie kann ich mir
so ein Experiment vorstellen?
Die Wissenschaftler
nahmen Schaufelnasen-Hammerhaie.
Sie haben sie zu 90%
mit Seegras ernährt
und haben noch 10% Tintenfisch
reingeworfen.
Das Seegras war markiert
mit einem bestimmten Kohlenstoff.
Wie ein Kontrastmittel.
Sie können so verfolgen,
wo der Kohlenstoff im Hai hingeht.
Sie haben den Kohlenstoff
tatsächlich verdauen
und in ihr Gewebe einbauen können.
Während des Experiments
sind die Haie auch gewachsen,
ihnen ging es gut.
Sie hatten
keine Mangelerscheinungen.
Voll gut.
Dann können wir festhalten:
Schaufelnasen-Hammerhaie
hätten einen guten Platz
in der Selbsthilfegruppe.
Sorry, Bruce und Hart,
euch bekommt das leider nicht so gut.
Außer, wir nehmen es wörtlich:
"Fische sind Freunde".
Das bedeutet,
sie können noch Säugetiere essen.
Wie Robben oder Delfine.
- Menschen.
Genau, das sind ja keine Fische.
So könnten sie sich weiter ernähren.
Schwierig könnte werden,
genug Nahrung zu finden.
Oder mein nächster Badeurlaub.
Hallo.
Es gibt also durchaus Haie,
die vegetarisch leben können.
Fischer sind cleverer,
als wir denken.
Und der Ostaustralstrom könnte Marlin
und Co. nach Sydney bringen.
Nur eben nicht zurück.
Danke fürs Erklären.
- Sehr gerne.
Wenn ihr mehr wissen wollt,
dann schaut in die Infobox.
Dort findet ihr ein paar Links,
Zum Beispiel zu deinem Buch.
Danke auch an Caro,
die uns die Szenen
zusammengefasst hat.
Vergesst ihr jetzt auf keinen Fall,
diesen Kanal zu ...
... abonnieren und Glocke drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Bis dann!
- Tschüss.
(mit verstellter Stimme)
Ihr wollt noch mehr Nemo-Content?
Den gibt es hier drüben.
Einen anderen Disney-Film
gibt es hier unten.
Oben.
UT: Copyright MDR 2023